hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the paul
morphy saga and
this is the last game uh from our blind
blindfold simultaneous exhibition match
in birmingham
uh where morphe is facing professor
reverend george salmon and george simon
was uh was an
incredible chess player himself as
you'll see here uh and
uh the game features uh well a move that
we have never seen on this channel it's
an evan's gambit variation and
the evans gambit gets declined but in a
very specific way i i don't think we've
ever shown this line
on the channel thus yet and george
salmon as it states on his
wikipedia page uh was a distinguished
and influential irish mathematician and
anglican theologian after working in
algebraic geometry for two decades
salmon devoted the last four years of
his life to theology and his entire
career was spent at
trinity college in dublin so uh as you
can see uh
definitely a mostly distinguished
gentleman as there is well
you can see by by his photo that it is
of an extremely high quality it could
also maybe be a drawing
because you can never tell maybe it was
just a drawing and someone drew
really well but i i actually think this
is a photo
uh so uh without further ado let's check
it out as this game is just
insane it's it could be the best
blindfold game that
i've ever seen uh but yeah uh let's just
check it out
so morphe again with the white pieces
opens with e4 and yes uh
when you're holding a simultaneous
exhibition you get the white pieces on
all boards
so e4 we have e5 knight to sword
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
c4 more figures for the italian game we
have bishop to c5
and in this position you uh don't have
to even question uh
what morphy will play as morphe in this
position always goes for the evan's
gambit
and that is b4 so the evans gambit is on
the board
and now we often say that the absolute
way to refute this idea
is to capture the gambit um is the
except the gambit with bishop captures
on b4
however there are people who have
sometimes declined this gambit with
moves like bishop to b6
or bishop to e7 even but here uh
reverend professor george salmon goes
for d5 and this is the so-called hein
counter gambit and it offers some very
very exciting play
so here morphy immediately captures uh e
captures and d5 but uh
interestingly our good friend yohanyako
bleventhal states that
uh e captures on d5 is not the way to go
that morphe should have gone bishop to
b5 which is extremely interesting
because bishop to b5 loses by force and
it loses by force the bishop captures an
f2
obviously something that morphe knew and
luventhal didn't but i will show it
because it's very interesting
king captures on f2 and only now d
captures on e4 and now you win back your
piece because the knight
cannot move if the knight moves for
example knight captures on e5
uh queen to d4 check nicely connects
with the king with the knight with
the rook uh and of course first you go
after the knight
uh so after the king moves let's say
king to e1 now you pick up the knight uh
the rook is still hanging white has to
defend
then you play knight f6 castle and black
is just better white's position is
already ruined
so uh just uh throwing it out there as
uh lentils said that uh you know
morphy should have played better with
bishop to b5 which is again very
interesting
as uh lost all of his matches to morphy
uh but he still uh finds it important
that he should comment uh you know
uh how how morphy who could have played
better uh so e captures on d5 the
absolute best move by morphe
knight captures on b4 and now morphy
just castles uh we have knight to e7
salmon prepares the castle and now
knight captures an e5
and here again you have to be very
careful uh because uh
well danger lurks everywhere and here
are salmon castles which is the best
move but again
uh lorenthal says that uh salmon should
have played better with bishop to d for
attacking the knight and the the rook
here on a1
uh sorry and the rook on a1 but this
again loses by force because here morphe
would have a knight captures on f7
attacking the queen and the rook and
after the knight is captured
this d6 check is just deadly uh if you
go knight e to d5 to block check yes the
knights are defending each other
but now c3 and now now you don't really
have a
a good move you have to move the bishop
bishop to f6 and now white even offers
the rook for two pieces it's not a
problem just captures captures and
captures with
check and the black is completely
destroyed two pieces for a rook
with a with a superior position now
white is winning this easily
so instead after knight captures an e5
uh salmon goes for the absolute best we
have castles here and now
d4 more morphe strikes in the center
bishop to d6
and now knight to c3 continuing
development with bishop to f5 now going
after the c2 pawn
and morphe defends it with bishop to b3
we have
a3 uh sorry first a5 of course uh going
after a4 to attack the bishop here so a3
morphe makes room for the light square
bishop also attacks the knight here
and now even a4 and this is again the
absolute best move so it's incredible
how good of a player our good friend
george salmon here is
uh even though morphe is playing
blindfold george is playing the absolute
best moves here so
knight captures on a4 grabbing that and
now knight
b captures on d5 so grabbing the d5 pawn
and here morphe just strikes in the
center with c4 now
uh forcing this knight to move and now
george again with the absolute best
stuff
rook captures an a4 and now he was
hoping for morphe to grab the exchange
with bishop captures on a4
and then he would have this very nice
knight to c3 fork the queen and the
bishop here
and okay the queen can go to b3 to
defend the bishop but then comes knight
to check king h1 and knight captures on
d4
shattering morphy center and uh yeah
black would have a very very interesting
uh
interesting game here even though down
down the exchange but uh
a lot of very active pieces developed
for example queen e3
attacks the knight then c5 defends it
and it's just a
very strong position for black so this
is what he was hoping for but
after rook captures an a4 morphe ignores
the rook and plays d
captures uh c captures on d5 now uh
the rook is still under attack and
george needs to move it
so rook to a5 and now comes queen to f3
by morphy so
just continuing development morphe wants
to get his bishop to b2
and then his bishop pair will be very
scary not yet fully operational but
you know at some point it might be so
the knight now cannot move because the
bishop will be hanging so bishop back to
g6 and now morphy continues development
rook to e1 and here we have a very very
interesting move uh george plays bishop
to b4 and this is george's first mistake
of the game
so uh up until this point it's been it's
been a pretty
pretty decent game you know okay he
didn't accept the evan's gambit but he
played in great style uh
after not accepting it so bishop to b4
attacking the rook here and of course if
the bishop is captured then rook
captures rook on a1
but this move loses by four so feel free
to pause the video and
win this game for morphe while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh
only move that wins and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's bishop to g5 and this is just a
very impressive move
uh point is the knight is now pinned the
knight cannot move and once this knight
moves you will have a double attack on
the e7 knight
and it doesn't matter if the rook is
captured if bishop captures rook rook
captures bishop again you have this here
and there's no way to defend once this
knight captures the bishop for example
then you will
lose the knight here on e7 and there is
no good way to defend against this
for example if you play something like
f6 to block this and also
try and win a piece here this loses
terribly to d6
check now uh the the king is in check
you have to defend
and if king to h8 then d captures on e7
attacking the queen and the queen
captures and now the incredible knight
captures on g6 with
check uh h captures and g6 and now queen
to h3 is checkmate as the bishop still
covers the g8 square
so bishop to g5 was in the position but
uh seems to be
a bit too much for our good friend
blindfold uh mr morphy
and morphe just moves the rook he plays
rook to e2
uh now gets the rook out of harm's way
and now comes knight to f5
okay now black definitely improved his
position a lot but
morphe continues with his plan bishop to
b2 now the bishops are very nicely
placed here
but you still have to get rid of those
pawns somehow to make the bishop
fully operational we have queen to a8
now with
a triple attack on this a3 pawn but just
g3
morphe makes room for his king so he
doesn't have to worry about backrank
weaknesses
and the a3 pawn is still off limits
because well
if you go after it then there's knight
to c4 just a double attack on the rook
and the bishop and that's
that's just it you lose a piece so
instead after g3
queen to a7 putting pressure on the d4
pawn
uh and now now finally knight captures
on g6
h captures and rook to e5 a very nice
rook lived by morphe
and there are a lot of complications in
the position but
this is one of those positions where the
most obvious move is actually the move
you have to play
and that's just grabbing the pawn knight
captures here and it's a it's a great
position for black
the queen is under attack the bishop is
under attack and it's crucial to
eliminate
uh one of those bishops captures
captures and now the game continues
with uh with an equalish game uh black
black even
could be somewhat better but instead
after this rook to e5 uh
george salmon for the first time doesn't
play the uh the
the strongest move okay there was this
one time that we've shown uh
two moves ago but here he plays bishop
captures an a3 and it seems like yes he
won a pawn
but this now loses terribly because of a
very specific idea
now for the last time feel free to pause
the video and win this game for morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
uh finding this brilliancy and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
d6 and i know us a lot of you
thought about d6 but then you thought
yeah okay i open up my bishop but what's
actually happening what's actually
happening is that now uh black's
rook is under attack on a5 that's the
point and uh if
if you allow rook capture screen
captures then the bishop is free for
grabs
and here if you go rook captures here
then just d captures on e5 and again
uh you're losing this bishop there's no
way no way to defend it
and there's also the the very
interesting line if you try and
sacrifice the exchange with bishop
captures on b2
not a problem we're just going to play
rook a characters on a5 and now after
queen captures on b4
uh you're gonna get bishop captures on
f7 this is awesome
rook captures and now rook the e8 with
check
king the h7 and now rook 8 to a8
threatening checkmate
and once black defense there's not a lot
of good ways to do this for example king
to h6 you can try and reach the g5
square
then the hunt really continues we're
gonna play d captures on c7
threaten to bring the queen into the
game and once black removes the
rook from the f file now we go in for
the kill rook h8
check king to g5 and now rook here
and there is not much for for black to
do h4 is an idea always in a lot of
lines
if the queen leaves control of the f4
square then queen to for his checkmate
and if you try anything else let's say
you just try pushing a pass pawn there's
the incredible uh
beautiful move rook to h5 with check so
ending with with
with a monster rook sacrifice g captures
removing the defender of the knight on
f5 and now
rook captures with check king the g6 and
the queen captures an h5 with
checkmate this is uh truly truly
impressive
so here after d6 uh our good friend
george salmon decided that
okay we can't play for the win anymore
we have to start defending he played
bishop to b4
just to add another defender to the rook
here but now it's not a problem
rook e captures here we have bishop
captures and now
uh the simplest way queen to d5 you
could also go for captures here
as it does make sense you create a pass
pawn but morphy goes for the more
forcing
queen to d5 now with a double attack on
the bishop
and after b6 defending now morphy just
advances the pawn to d7 now threatening
to bring another queen into the game
so salmon defense here defends the the
d8 square but now just
rook to c1 and even though salmon is now
uh able to exchange queens and he does
it's still
uh an unplayable position for black so
captures captures
uh and now b5 the c7 point is under
attack so b5 he defends it now comes
bishop to c6
going after this pawn salmon defends it
and now
d5 and now what do you play here how do
you bring this rook into the game
it's it it doesn't seem to be possible
so here
bishop the d2 shifting the rook over to
the bishop to the king side
rook to d1 and now bishop to g5 guarding
the square
now maybe you could somehow activate the
rook but it's very hard maybe something
like this
but still it's uh that's a lot of moves
so here f4
morphe further attacks this bishop
bishop to d8
and now comes bishop to a3 and look at
black's pieces
the bishop know where to go the knight
cannot move because the rook
would hang the rook cannot move so this
is just a
this is one of the the worst positions
um i've ever seen and
imagine getting to this position by uh
you know
playing against someone who's playing
blindfold and not just playing blindfold
but playing blindfold against seven
other players
so this is uh unimaginable so here f5
tries to create some room for the king
to come back into the game
rook to e1 by morphe now the the rook
can also
for example go to e8 at any point you
can capture the knight remove the
defender
the rook will never can never be
captured there but okay
uh king to f7 is coming so such ideas
will have to wait
king to f7 and now bishop captures on b5
there's there was no way to avoid this
the knight cannot capture because the
rook hangs
uh and here and okay you might think but
why not just capture it i mean it's two
uh two pieces for the rook but still
after captures this
uh the problem now is that uh well if
if black captures this just rook the e8
to check and this bishop is lost so
you're going to win that piece as well
and then it's the game
so here after bishop captures on b5
broke the h8
there's nothing to do here and now black
does not have a single move black will
just have to move the rook back and
forth and
morphe will bring his king all the way
from g1
uh all the way up there uh okay
the knight will be eliminated all the
way to c8 and then
that's just game so here king to f2
morphy starts with the king march
and uh sorry not king of two first the
bishop captures removing the knight as
he starts with that c captures on e6 and
now
rook to e8 offering this rook trade so
if you move the rook anywhere then
bishop is lost and if you don't then the
rook is lost so there's only one good
move here and that's
rook to f8 uh just uh keeping uh
uh keeping the the rooks on the board
and now white will not be able to
capture as then
it should be a draw for black so king f2
starting to bring the king into the game
now g5 uh morphe just continues with the
king we have g4
king to d3 now we have g5 by black and
now
bishop to c6 we have g captures on f4
g captures on f4 and now rook to g8 but
it doesn't matter just king to c4
there's no way no no good way to
continue playing this the rook has to
go back and forth so rook to f8 king to
b5
we have rook to g8 now comes king to a6
rook to f8 and now king to b7 uh rook to
g8 and now king to c8 finally
ready to win this bishop and now there's
nothing more to be done bishop has to
move and now
it's finally game over rook captures
ng-8 king captures
and the d8 promoting a pawn to a queen
bishop captures king captures and it was
in this position that
george salmon resigned to the game as
there was nothing more to be done here
and absolute brilliancy by paul morphy
so just a remarkable opening
and it's hard to say uh i've never seen
and we've covered
a lot of morphe games and uh i've seen a
lot of games that i haven't covered here
i haven't i i don't think i've ever seen
morphe face the declined
evans gambit with the d5 and now he
played it the blindfold so that makes it
even more impressive
uh that he was able to uh to create this
brilliancy and then he he just
tied him down completely traded down
into an end game
and then played just a beautiful
beautiful end game with this king march
going all the way from g1
to uh to d8 to win the game so this is
uh
i don't i don't recall seeing a
blindfold game uh
that was this good and not just morphe
uh our good friend george salmon also
played a brilliant game he made
he made a few mistakes but uh i mean who
could
who could expect a morphe to you know
spot them blindfold why
while facing eight opponents
simultaneously so incredible incredible
stuff like i said this
this is the last game that we'll be
showing from the uh blindfold
simultaneous exhibition uh
in birmingham and we are continuing the
morphe saga with some other matches so
will there be more blindfold matches
will morphy face some other adversaries
or will he finally face
uh staunton for for the title of the
greatest player in the world
uh we'll have to see but for that we do
have the
rest of the morphe saga so yeah
that's the game and this entire
blindfold saga exhibition
i hope you guys enjoyed that i would
like to thank ellie finkelstein uh
alexander hutchinson
rodney lloyd harold clark and eric novak
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank y'all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
yes we will have a tall game for
uh this channel reaching 1 million
subscribers i'm i'm waiting for my gold
youtube button to arrive
so i can properly make that video but
worry not it is coming
see you soon